hablemos de lo que va a pasar con la
commonwealth ee se prevé que pueda haber
algún cambio después de este cambio de
cabeza en el trono
para muchas limitaciones 24 8 empezaría
diciendo pues que va a ser un periodo de
un año de muchos cambios de muchos
desafíos para el nuevo rey para el rey
carlos teniendo en cuenta pues que a
partir de hoy de ese momento él ya es el
rey ya la casa real se refiere a de como
el rey los medios de comunicación es los
políticos se refieren a ver como rey
mañana el parlamento va a juramentar su
lealtad con el rey carlos iii a partir
de ahora vamos a tener sesiones
extraordinarias luego de la muerte de la
reina en los parlamentos de irlanda del
norte en el parlamento de escocia en el
parlamento de gales en el parlamento de
inglaterra y en los demás países que
conforman en commonwealth también como
un símbolo de de lealtad al nuevo rey
luego de esto los parlamentos para dejar
de sesionar por diez días un período de
diez días que va a ser un símbolo de
luto pero el cual va a empezar a mostrar
nada lenta transición ya tenemos mucha
ya hay un rey en inglaterra en ese
momento
el proceso de digamos de establecimiento
de carlos como un monarca como de
conocer los rasgos de carlos como
monarca pero va a ser un proceso lento
vamos a tener la coronación de carlos
quizás en más de un año hay que recordar
que por ejemplo cuando el rey jorge sexo
padre de la reina isabel murió en 1952
pues inmediatamente la reina fue
digamos nombrada ascendió como reina
pero solamente hasta junio de 1953 es
decir un año y cuatro meses después es
que tiene la ceremonia de coronación
luego hace incluso largo
campos muy lentos en que también tener
en cuenta que por ejemplo los billetes
el himno toda la simbología relacionada
con la monarquía va a ser reemplazada
alguna cara del nuevo rey luego son
cambios muy lentos que vamos el
y bueno hablando de cambios estamos en
tiempos de cambios en el reino unido-
lynch trozo de que llegó recientemente
en reemplazo de boris johnson y carlos
tercero que llega a reemplazar a su
madre isabel segundo después de su
fallecimiento usted como politólogo como
una persona experta en el tema pues cómo
evalúa esto esta subida de cambios que
llegan al país como afectaría esto a
nivel político y a nivel internacional
para usted esto tiene algo un efecto más
allá del simbolismo del evento
bueno cuando hablamos normalmente angela
de momentos de largos reinos hablamos
por entre el reino de la reina victoria
por ejemplo el reino de isabel primera
hora y sabe segundo estos reinos largos
suelen ser una garantía de estabilidad
una garantía de que las condiciones
políticas
económicas e internacionales pues van a
ser relativamente estables y cuando
vemos un cambio tan abrupto en el que en
un periodo apenas dos días en muere la
reina llega una nueva primera ministra y
un nuevo rey comienza pues sin duda
alguna ver una transición política muy
grande que puede tener implicaciones en
muchos sentidos por ejemplo una
aprobación que la realeza tiene ante la
sociedad orgánica estamos hablando de
que la sociedad británica por más de 70
años ha tenido a la reina isabel como su
monarca y que por ende la monarquía es
casi sinónimo del nombre de isabel y que
ahora que llegó una monarca pues tendrá
que ganarse también el aprecio y el
respeto de los británicos
en ese pues en ese sentido pues puede
haber mucho cambio en la presunción
ciudadana frente a la monarquía hay que
recordar que más bien monarquistas lo
que los británicos son era isabel istas
quería mucho a la reina isabel que se
había convertido pues casi que en parte
permanente de la vida en el reino unido
por siete décadas así que pues
definitivamente vienen muchos cambios en
ese sentido en la forma que la
ciudadanía interpreta la monarquía y
también hablar de de una dirección muy
importante que se ha dado por esta época
en el redimido y en la permanencia de
escocia la permanencia de escocia así
como en tiempos anteriores también se ha
hablado de la permanencia en irlanda del
norte en esta guerra civil con irlanda
del norte de modo que todos esos son
debates la permanencia de sus estados
así como los otros catorce estados
miembros del commonwealth y cuáles van a
pensar en irse cuáles van a ser las
condiciones para ellos permanecer todo
eso va a ser un debate que se va de hoy
que se abre hoy y además esto me lleva a
preguntarle ahora por la importancia
entre las relaciones y entre esa dupla
que tiene que existir entre la primera
ministra y el rey carlos tercero usted
como ve esa relación y cómo podría
influenciar todas estas dificultades
políticas que nos mencionaba como
irlanda del norte
bueno finalmente él la figura monárquica
es una figura que más que todo para
velar los intereses de una nación de una
imagen de una nación de personificar
unos valores de una nación y que intenta
en muchos sentidos no participar en
decisiones políticas a la reina isabel
le tocó una muy difícil que fue el break
seal y le tocó aceptar lo que ocurriera
con el break shit le tocó adherida a lo
que había sido una decisión popular a
pesar de muy seguramente que no
estuviera de acuerdo con eso y así como
esa decisión le tocó por ejemplo la
llegada en los años 60 del primer
ministro wilson un primer ministro
conectaba mucha diferencia con la casa
real
más recientemente la llegada de bolillos
y la reina siempre estuvo mal y supo
mantener una distancia con lo político
ella sabía que su rol era encabezar y
personificar lo que realizado ni está ni
incluye el estado de los diferentes
miembros del commonwealth pero nunca
meterse en las decisiones ni en los
debates coyunturales ahora bien también
sabemos que a carlos le van a tocar esos
but es muy profundo de inmediato y lleva
a que tomar una postura frente a esto si
va a ser un primer ministro si va a ser
perdón monarca que va a tener una
relación más política con los primeros
ministros cuyos partidos con gabinetes o
si va a seguir el ejemplo de su madre de
no participar en temas políticos en
mantener una relación armónica y sobre
todo de aceptar que su rol implica
mantener esa cierta distancia pero como
en como le digo pues ya tenemos unos
antecedentes donde la reina tuvo un tuvo
que aceptar unas decisiones que no
podían haber sido exagerado pero que aún
así lo hizo particularmente la reciente
decisión con respecto al breaking ahora
van a venir nuevos debates el debate que
tiene lugar en este momento de escocia
el debate que ha tenido lugar desde el
siglo 17 sobre la permanencia de irlanda
del norte y que sea reactivo mucho en la
primera y la segunda mitad del siglo 20
y que hoy en día pues todavía tiene un
debate profundo así que a cargo de va a
tocar todos esos debates y empezando por
uno que va a ser el más elemental que va
a ser ganarse el aprecio y el respeto de
la ciudadanía